NARRATOR: The
following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ready to go on
lecture five, I guess this is.
So this -- we've done the
one-way wave equation,
first-order equation and now
it's just natural to see what
about the ordinary, second-order
wave equation and on this
board, I've written it two ways.
I've written it as a
second-order equation,
so second time
derivative appears.
That's going to make a change.
It will have second
differences in time,
so we're going to
have more steps,
and of the matching second
difference in space.
That's one way.
Then this is another
important way
to write the same equation
as a first-order system.
So I can get back to first-order
systems and I can use all those
methods -- Friedrichs,
Lax-Friedrichs for example,
Lax-Wendroff, whatever
improvements we think of --
on this first order system, d
by dt of a vector is a matrix
times d by dx of a vector.
So that's -- you really
have a choice here.
Written this way, well,
notice a little bit
of a good thing,
one good thing here.
The matrix that shows
up is symmetric.
That was by the careful choice
of putting a c in there.
Then you see that the first
equation in this system is u_tt
is c time c*u_xx.
So the first equation
is the wave equation.
And what about the
second equation?
This is typical, when
you reduce things
to a lower-order system,
that you get an equation here
which is just an identity.
The derivative of c -- the
time -- this is c*u_xt --
it's the derivative in
x and t from there --
and we have c times the
x derivative of u_t,
the cross derivative.
So that is an identity because
u_tx is the same as u_xt.
We can take time and x and t
derivatives in either order,
for a function of x and t.
So we'll see that.
I guess what I want to
do in the lecture is not
to repeat Lax-Friedrichs or
Lax-Wendroff for this system.
That would be unexciting.
Let me just mention, what are
the eigenvalues of that matrix?
So the eigenvalues
-- for a system,
it's the eigenvalues of the
matrix that tell us what waves
we've got, what speeds they go,
where it -- when it was 1 by 1,
of course, it was just
that single number c,
but what are the
eigenvalues of that matrix?
Now, having made it
a symmetric matrix,
we know right away it
has real eigenvalues,
and so it's a wave problem.
For a heat equation, we would
see something different,
but this'll be a wave equation
and this has two eigenvalues
and they are c and minus c.
You could quickly check
that that 2 by 2 matrix
has eigenvalues c and minus c.
They add up to 0,
which is the trace.
They multiply -- c times
minus c is minus c squared,
which is the determinant.
So that's -- they're
the right eigenvalues.
So that's going to tell us
what we'll find every way,
that the speeds of the waves
are c and minus c, which
means a wave going
one way with speed c
and a wave going the
other way with speed c.
So it's a two-way wave equation.
And this is the equation of
real -- that really happens,
and I wanted to say just
a little bit about it --
just two words
about real problems,
because we can't,
in these first days,
tackle the difficult
problems of electromagnetism,
antenna design, all
kinds of wave problems.
I guess I'm hoping some of
you may be meeting real wave
problems in other courses and
would make a project that tries
our methods on real problems.
I just wanted to
write down here one
sort of typical real problem.
So in a real problem, we have
a variable coefficient x,
because maybe our material
is not homogeneous,
it's not uniform, and we
have a forcing term --
I just put F for the amplitude
to emphasize that's forcing
term, so F standing for forcing,
but it's an oscillating forcing
term, it's a -- this is
what you're going to have.
In electromagnetism,
the frequency
is going to be very, very high.
So this is a problem that's
not easy numerically.
Very, very high
frequencies would normally
require very, very small
wavelengths, very, very
small delta x,
because you remember,
there'll be a k
delta x in the error.
So we took a big delta x or
even an ordinary size delta
x and let the frequency go way,
way up, high, high frequency
oscillation, our k
delta x would be big
and the accuracy would be
poor and the results useless.
So a lot of -- I'm really --
guess I'm thinking here about
a course on wave propagation
would study this as a first
model problem, do some analysis
and then go into 2-D and 3-D.
That's the reality
of wave theory,
is you can get asymptotic
results for k going
to infinity.
You get things -- you're
looking in matching powers of k,
so to speak.
You're getting plane waves
and interesting stuff
that we can't do
already, right away here.
So I'm going back to the
ordinary wave equation,
either second or --
start with second order,
u_tt is c squared u_xx.
That's our goal.
As I said, we don't want to see
Lax-Friedrichs and Lax-Wendroff
again.
We know those.
It's rather -- so one new method
is going to show up and it's --
leapfrog is the right name,
the natural name to give it.
Leapfrog because in
the time direction,
we have time n minus
1, n and n plus 1.
There's a leap there, but let
me start with semidiscrete.
We haven't done
this until today.
Semidiscrete means, as you
see, that the time variable
stays continuous.
We have ordinary
differential equations in t,
but the space variable is
what's getting discrete.
so the problem is like half
discrete -- discrete in x,
there's a delta x, but
there's no delta t yet.
So it's natural to
analyze this problem.
So what do we have, really?
In the x direction, we have
a mesh of width delta x.
So we have unknowns.
If that's 0, j is measuring
-- so j delta x is the typical
point, point number
j along there.
And then in the time direction,
we're going continuously.
So I don't have discrete
steps, so it's called --
because those are lines in
the time direction, this is --
semidiscrete is also referred
to as the method of lines.
So the method of lines is what
we're doing here and it's --
all I want to do is
what I always do.
Take exponentials, look
at their growth factors,
understand the equation.
Actually, I better do it first
with a wave equation itself.
So I guess my
organization for today is,
first step is follow e to the
i*k*x for the wave equation.
So I'll do that here.
u_tt equals c squared u_xx,
and I'm going to look at u
proportional to -- and I'll
call this factor G again --
G of t and times
the frequency i*k*x.
So I'm going to look
for pure exponentials
and we'll quickly find them.
And then I'm going to do
the same for semidiscrete,
where that x becomes j
delta x and I'm at point j.
And then I'm going to eventually
look at the discrete, now fully
discrete, discrete in time
and discrete in space,
and the question of
stability arises.
Accuracy we can --
you pretty much --
we pretty much know the
accuracy for second differences,
that's a second-order accurate
thing because it's centered,
but stability is
going to come in.
So that's -- this
is our first step.
Then I'll just mention
what other point
remains in this wave
equation, is to look
at the first-order system.
How does that look
in space and time?
As I said, the
obvious thing to do
would be Lax-Friedrichs
or Lax-Wendroff,
but there's another idea and
it brings in a staggered grid.
You'll see it.
Somehow that staggered grid
is really an important idea
that we haven't met yet.
That some unknowns are on
the standard grid, U_(j, n),
but the other unknowns are on
a grid that's half a delta x
and half a delta t different.
It's just right, actually.
So that's a premier method
in electromagnetism.
So that's what's
coming, but let's start
with the second-order
method, because we haven't
seen the second-order method.
Second-order equation --
plug in G. So I have --
the second time derivative
gives me G double prime times e
to the i*k*x -- I'm separating
variables, of course;
t here and x there.
On the other side,
I have c squared.
Now I have the x variable,
so that brings down an i*k --
so that's i*k squared
times G e to the i*k*x.
Good.
So simple, but substituting this
is just a natural first step
to see what's happening.
Then, of course, canceling e
to the i*k*x leaves us with
the equation for the
G. G double prime is --
I'll make that i squared minus
-- minus c squared k squared G.
Of course, the new aspect
is it's second order.
So it's got two solutions
instead of just one.
It's constant
coefficients, of course,
and so we look for exponentials.
And the solution then would be
-- two solutions are some --
there's an e to the i -- I
guess I'm bringing back the i --
e to the i*c*k*t e to the i*k*x
and e to the minus i*c*k*t e
to the i*k*x.
Those are the two possible G's.
Those are the -- if we take
their second time derivative,
we get the same as taking
the second x derivative.
We get the factor c
is in the right place.
You'll see it.
The second time derivative
brings this factor down,
just as we wanted, but the point
is that there are two of them.
So this I can write as
e to the i*k x plus ct.
That's our old friend.
This one I can write as
e to the i*k x minus ct,
which is our new
friend, the new wave.
The wave that's
going to the right.
So this x plus c*t follows
the characteristic lines
to the left, just the way we had
in the one-way wave equation.
This x minus c*t stays constant
on characteristic lines going
up to the right; it travels with
speed c and the signal travels
along those characteristics
with speed c, so that a --
an initial value, now -- maybe
I draw a picture over here --
so here is t equals --
this is x as always.
This is t equals 0.
I have some initial
value u at (0, 0),
and I also have an initial
velocity, because I'm in --
got a second-order equation,
but information somehow,
pure exponential information
travels along characteristics
this way -- that's
the new one --
and characteristics this
way -- that's the old one.
This is time, space.
I'm graphing the two
characteristic lines now.
x minus c*t equals --
if it starts from 0,
then it would be 0.
This is the x plus c*t equals
0, the one we had before.
The two characteristic lines.
Waves are going
both ways, right?
Now, what we were able to do
with the first-order equation
-- we even got a completely
explicit solution
to the one-way wave equation
and we can do the same
for the two-way wave equation,
so I better write it down.
I better write
down the solution.
So let me just continue
this same idea.
The general, the complete
solution will be u of x and t
is some function of x minus
c*t and some function of --
call that f_2 -- of x plus c*t.
Now I'm taking the jump, the
jump from one exponential,
a particular k that gave
me these particular guys,
to all exponentials and
assembling all exponentials
into functions.
So why is that OK?
It's only OK in this because
of this very special situation
that all frequencies are
behaving the same here.
All frequencies -- I
have no dispersion.
Dispersion is going to
be different behavior
of different frequencies,
so that's an important fact,
which we don't face here.
There will be dispersion
in the discrete methods,
the semidiscrete and
the discrete method.
Different frequencies will
travel at different speeds
and that's what produces
the oscillating error.
Whatever shape the error has is
because different k's are doing
slightly different
things, as we'll see
when we do the discrete ones.
But in the continuous case,
every k, we have the same --
traveling either with speed
c or minus c and therefore,
we put them all together and we
have a whole function traveling
with speed c or minus c.
Now we've got two
functions and we
have to do we have to match
two initial conditions.
We have to match a u of x
and 0 and the time derivative
has to match a u_t
of x and 0, so these
are the initial conditions.
You just match them up
and you find the answer.
So you discover what these
functions really are.
It turns out that, I think,
we had -- you remember before,
we had a u of x plus c*t and 0?
That was everything in the
solution to the one-way wave
equation.
Now we will have u of x minus
c*t, 0 and this divided by 2 --
so there, you see, a wave's
going each way and the division
by 2 makes us -- now we're
matching the initial condition,
so that would be the total
answer if the equation,
if the body starts from
rest with zero velocity,
but I haven't matched -- so I've
only matched du/dt equals 0 --
think the time derivative
of that would be 0.
Yeah, because the time
derivative of this would bring
out a c, this would bring out
a minus c and a t equals 0,
they'd cancelled.
So I need another term
and it turns out to be --
I'll just write it down.
It's got to depend on x
minus c*t and x plus c*t
and it's this -- it's the
integral of this velocity dx.
I won't -- there's no reason
to take time to derive that.
I think it's right
and could check.
Right.
So what this means is that
the initial velocity is --
it's entering,
somehow, all along --
somehow the initial velocity
is affecting things within this
cone, this characteristic
cone that's defined
by the characteristic lines.
In two dimensions, that cone
will really look like a cone.
It'll look like an
ice cream cone --
or maybe that's in
three dimensions.
Whatever.
In other words, if
the initial condition
was a delta function
at the origin,
you could quickly see what
the solution would be,
and if the delta, if
the initial condition
was a step function at the
origin, what would happen then?
Suppose I started with this
step function at the origin.
So, like, a wall of water
and suppose it's at rest.
So nothing -- at
moment t equals 0,
I remove the dam and the water
starts -- the water flows.
Then this term is 0 because
there was no initial velocity
and this term is just half
of that wall goes one way
and half goes the other way.
The notes draw a picture of
that, so that -- so that's --
I've kind of quickly disposed
of the solution of the wave
equation and of course,
that's too easy.
This is -- I mean, that's good
to know and good to compare
when we meet real problems
where c depends on x,
where there's a forcing
term, where there's a --
real complications.
But it just pays to stay
with the model problems
at the beginning.
So, I'm going to stay with
the model problem and move
on to discrete, so
try to understand --
let me try to understand what
happens if I make the space
variable discrete, right?
I guess I should say,
another step toward reality
would be, have some boundaries.
Here, this is on the whole
line, x from minus infinity
to infinity, so reality would
be that there would be --
this picture would have some
boundary, maybe there at, say,
minus L and L, and some
boundary conditions there,
on that boundary.
And that -- so now we
have a finite problem.
That means the
calculations are fine,
but it means some new
effects are coming in.
Waves can bounce back
off the boundary, partly.
They can go out,
be lost, go beyond
or disappear, depending what
the boundary conditions are.
So that's another
part of reality,
is boundary conditions.
I'm probably suggesting,
then, some more realistic
numerical experiments.
So a realistic
numerical experiment
would be, put in
some boundaries,
make this a finite system.
So if that's 0, let's just have
a finite number, stop there.
This would be one boundary,
this would be the other.
Then I have just seven
unknowns in that problem.
That'd be a seven by
seven matrix over there
and it would be the
second difference
matrix that is so fundamental
in all of scientific computing.
So we have here a second
difference matrix,
but it's infinite
because I haven't
got a boundary right now.
So the fact of not
having a boundary
means Fourier is ready to go.
So I'm going to plug in --
again, I'm going to try U.
This is capital U now, because
I've discretized something.
I better write this in a
form where we see the j,
so can I write this equation,
just again for U number j --
so tracking up this line,
for example, or this one.
So I'm tracking up this line
-- do you see that U is now
a system?
In this case -- let's see.
I shouldn't have put this one in
so that I'd have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7 -- that's good.
So my unknowns are U_j
tracking up that line.
Each U_j is going in
the time direction,
so this equation is really
the time derivative.
It's an ordinary derivative.
I can write d and not
partial derivative,
because the only derivatives
here are in time of U_j --
is c squared over delta x
squared times U_(j+1) minus
2*U_j plus U_(j-1).
That's my equation.
My system of equations, sorry.
My system of equations.
For the moment, I'm thinking
j goes from minus infinity
to infinity.
I'm not going to put in a
boundary, but what I will do,
of course, is try U_j is
some growth factor that --
j is a space, is
counting space steps,
so the growth factor is in time
and it's continuous in time,
because time's continuous,
but it's always e to the i*k*j
delta x.
That's the right
thing to plug in.
I mean, I guess what we're
-- what I'm really --
the reason for really doing this
is just to reinforce the idea
that trying a pure exponential
is a good thing to do.
It's even a good thing to do
with variable coefficients
and real problems.
It's absolutely a good thing to
do with these model problems.
Plug it in and what happens?
So I get G double prime
times the exponential,
but of course you
know in advance,
I'm going to cancel
that exponential --
is c squared over delta
x squared times --
what goes there?
What will cancel
the exponential --
so I'm imagining that
exponential as far out,
but here it is at j plus 1.
So I've incremented j by 1, so
that is going to give me an e
to the i*k delta x, right?
Here I haven't incremented it
and here I've incremented it
by minus 1, so that will give me
an e to the minus i*k delta x,
all times the same exponential
which appeared there
and appeared there
and got cancelled.
So that's it there.
G double prime -- oh there's
got to be a G -- right,
there's a G. Right.
When I plugged in on
the right-hand side
I got a G that was so
uninteresting I lost it.
What does -- what's G there?
I guess the main point to see
is, this quantity, which is --
divided by delta x squared,
which is coming because we have
differences instead
of derivatives.
When we had derivatives, that
quantity was c squared i*k
squared.
Or, in other words, minus
c squared k squared.
This was the correct factor and
this one is the discrete factor
and it's worth just paying
a moment of attention
to compare the two.
Where am I going to
write that comparison?
I guess that's going to be
on the board that's hidden,
so I'm going to -- can
you try to remember that?
Let me focus just on this
quantity for a minute, or even
just on this one, just because
we see it so many times,
because it's coming directly
from second differences.
For the moment, let
me take k delta x.
I'll just call it theta.
It's some angle.
So can I just do a little
bit of trig with this factor?
2 minus 2 cos theta.
Let's see.
I'm going to, I'm going
to bring out a minus sign.
So I'm going to put
plus signs on those
and minus signs on those.
You see the main
point of course,
that e to the plus
something, e to the i theta
and e to the minus i theta
combine to give 2 cos theta.
Right, so that's the key
simplification that's
going to make this much neater.
So I have 2 cos theta minus 2.
I have 2 cos theta minus 2, and
if I bring out a minus sign,
I'll have 2 minus 2
cos theta and that's
what I want to write.
I want to write 2
minus 2 cos theta.
I want to see what
that expression is.
Right, so that brought
out a minus sign just
to match that minus sign
and the c squareds match,
but what's different is
this k squared is now
gone into this 2 minus 2
cos k delta x I'll write it,
divided by delta x squared.
You see that this is
-- that's the change.
k squared, which is
a positive quantity
became this, which is also a
positive quantity, 2 minus 2
cos theta, but it's
not a pure k squared.
We are getting dispersion.
Different frequencies are
showing up inside the cosine
and that's not a
linear function.
So we're seeing
different frequencies
going their own way in a more
interesting way then just what
we saw here with k squared.
Of course, when we take the
square root, as we did here,
that produced linear in k and
no dispersion and something
simple, but here, when we
take the square root --
let's get ready to
take the square root.
How can we take the
square root of that?
By writing it as a square.
It's never negative, and if I
use a little trigonometry --
so I'm just going
to write it down.
This is 4 -- I think it's
sine squared of theta over 2.
That's just a handy fact.
It's handy because I can take
its square root and really see
what -- so theta -- remember
this theta is standing for k
delta x.
So then, I want to divided
it by delta x squared.
Can I bring down that quantity
just so you see it again?
So this was the 2 minus 2 cos
theta with the minus sign,
and dividing by delta
x squared and that's --
so it was G double prime
-- let's just write it.
So I have G -- I'm now
going to copy what --
G double prime was a minus sign
times the c squared times this
-- 4 sine squared of k delta
x on 2 divided by delta x
squared.
Maybe I'll put the delta
x squared over there,
where it kind of belongs.
Times G, always
forgetting G. So we're
just following the
golden way here,
plugging in an exponential
and seeing what happens,
and what happens is pretty nice.
We now know what
the solutions are.
There'll be two solutions.
It's a linear problem,
so the solutions
will be exponential in t.
The solutions will
have a plus or minus i,
because it's a minus sign.
So G -- can I write it this way?
G of -- the solution to this,
or the two exponential solutions
will be e to the
plus or minus --
now I'm going to take
this square root --
i times c times the
square root of this.
Actually, that's not so hard.
2 -- that was our
point, wasn't it?
Sorry, I forgot about that --
sine k delta x over 2 divided
by delta x -- and look,
here's something nice.
Bring the 2 down there.
Make it 1/2 of the denominator.
Do you see what
this expression is?
Actually, do you know its name?
It's the sinc function.
It's the sinc function, right?
And for very small delta
x -- oh, times t, right?
It just -- we just
have an exponential.
Of course we do.
This was a constant
coefficient problem in t,
and a second order, so
I had two exponentials,
and I just took the square
root of that coefficient,
put it there, times t.
Absolutely straightforward.
This quantity is
the key one and this
is the quantity which, for
small k or small delta x,
is approximately what?
So if k and delta x are
small, or if even just delta x
is small, what does this
sinc function look like?
What is that ratio
approximately, when k is small?
What does the sine of
theta look like when
theta is a small angle?
Looks like theta, right?
Sine theta is about theta.
So this thing is about k delta
x over 2 divided by delta --
it's k, so it's approximately
k for small delta x, let's say.
Delta x is small.
That's the key thing to know
about the sinc function,
that it begins by approximating
the sine function,
but then of course, when k delta
x gets large, it wanders away.
It's not linear in k.
See, it starts out
practically linear in k,
and that k is
exactly the right k.
That's the right factor.
That's the k here.
But in the
differential equation,
it stayed k and in the
difference equation,
for k delta x moving away,
it changes and that's why --
of course, that's the
source of the error.
We're seeing now why
the method is probably
second-order accuracy.
We know that these second
differences are second --
give second-order accuracy.
This would be -- if I
looked at the next term,
what's the next
term in sine theta?
Sine theta starts
out theta and then,
what's the term after that?
Everybody's Taylor series or --
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] theta cubed,
it's a theta cubed term.
Exactly, it's a minus theta
cubed over 6, three factorial,
but it's a theta cubed term.
And so the theta gave
us the right thing
and then two more
powers of theta
will give us a
second-order error, right?
I better move since -- so that's
the story for semidiscrete.
Semidiscrete produced
a pure exponential,
but with a phase
factor, you could say,
that wasn't linear in k
where the real one was.
Now, what about -- let me
move up to that board above,
where now we're going to have
-- we have it's discrete in time
as well, so we're going
to have single steps.
What's going to
be the difference?
Again, I'm going
to try -- you know,
I only have one idea here
-- U_(j, n) will be some G,
some growth factor, times
e to the i*j*k delta x.
The same -- I'm going to
try an e to the i*k*x,
and in the space variable, it
will be G. And after n steps,
it'll be G n times.
So this is the discrete, right?
This is the ansatz,
to use a fancy word.
This is what you plug in.
Little crazy to use
the word ansatz, which
sounds fancy and the word
plug, which is far from fancy.
I should say substitute.
Substitute in it.
All right.
Do we know what the
process is going to do?
When I plug it in -- sorry,
substitute it in on the left,
we get -- and I'm going to
cancel this from every term --
so all I'm interested
in is the --
maybe I'll cancel
G to the n minus 1.
So let me write down what I get.
This is going to give me
-- in the time direction,
I'll have a G squared minus a 2G
plus a 1 over delta t squared,
and in the space direction,
which is at the centered time,
so it's going to multiply a
G, it's going to be my same,
my very same thing.
I could maybe give
it a name here.
I don't know whether --
should I give it a name?
I know what it is
anyway, because it's
the same thing that I had
in the semidiscrete method.
It's this -- let's see
what it looked like.
At this point, it was --
look, let's do one thing.
Let me get this delta t squared
up there times the c squared
divided by the delta x squared.
Let me just clean
up those constants,
so that when I multiply up
by the delta t squared times
the c squared divided by the
delta x squared, what's that?
c delta t over delta x squared
is my old ratio, the Courant
number r, squared, and
then it's this times G.
So this will all be
just exactly the same
and that's what I
simplified here.
Let me just leave it
as -- with a minus.
Let me remember that I did take
a minus so that I could write
it as 2 minus 2 cosine of k
delta x times G. Is that --
I really think I have kept
track of everything here.
The r squared coming from
all this stuff, the minus 2
coming here and the plus 2
cosine coming from there.
You OK with that?
But there's one new
ingredient here.
Again, G to the n -- I cancelled
G to the n minus 1 times this
from every term.
So the new ingredient, that we
just have five minutes to deal
with, is the fact
that we have second --
G squared just showed up.
So why did G squared show up?
Because it's a multistep
method and therefore,
I've got two G's.
Of course.
I had two G's in all
these other cases
because I had second
derivatives and now I
have second differences.
So I have two G's, so I
have to solve for G --
and what is stability
going to depend on?
Stability is going
to be whether G --
both G's, because there
are two of them now --
are less than or equal to 1.
That's what I have to check
and that's the equation.
What do we figure?
We figure that if r is pretty
big -- if r is big, no way.
If r is big, the
Courant test will fail
and stability will fail.
But if r is small,
then I expect --
I have a right to
hope for stability.
So it's going to
be the size of r.
So I just have to -- I've
got this quadratic equation.
I'm going to bring
this thing over here.
I'm going to write this as
G squared minus 2a*G plus 1
equals 0, where a is this
quantity -- So I had minus 2a,
so a is a 1 from there, and when
I bring this over to the other
side, it's going to be a plus
r squared -- factoring out --
notice the 2 is everywhere.
So I put the 2 here.
The a comes from the 1
there and from this times
the r squared 1 plus r squared
minus r squared cos k delta x.
I'm just doing algebra and
it's coming out nicely.
It's coming out
to a nice equation
here with a slightly
messy expression for a,
but now that I've named this
quantity a, I can solve this.
So what's the solution?
I remember the quadratic formula
and I get G as 1, I think,
plus or minus the square
root of 1 minus a squared.
That's G. Oh, maybe this
is an a; probably is.
I guess the quadratic equation
takes a little memorizing,
but I guess the first point
is that that coefficient shows
up there and then the
square root that we know.
So what's up?
Again, none of this is deep.
I'm just following
my one-way path.
Check stability.
Check the size of G.
Get an equation for G.
Get a formula for
G and look at it.
So a is some positive
number and the key
is going to be whether
a is bigger than 1
or smaller than 1.
If a is -- is that right, 1
minus a squared or should that
be a squared minus 1?
Is it a squared minus 1?
Professors are not responsible
for the quadratic formula
because we proved that we
could do it in third grade
and lost it since.
I guess it's right.
Is that right?
Because look, here's the story.
Suppose a is bigger than 1.
Suppose -- I'm really looking
at the roots of this equation.
Notice, by the way, the
roots of that equation
multiply to give 1.
So I'm on the edge here.
Either both roots have size 1 or
one of those roots is too big.
The test is going to be, is
a greater than 1? a greater
than 1 will be unstable. a
less than 1 will be stable
and I'll connect a less
than 1 to r less than 1.
That will give me r less than 1.
All right.
I've given away the result
because time is pressing.
Let me just take the
remaining time to see this.
Suppose a is bigger than 1.
I'm just looking at the
roots of this equation
and here they are.
If a is bigger than 1, like 2,
I have 2 plus square root of 3,
I'm way up, right?
I'm bigger than 1, no question.
Suppose a is less than 1.
Suppose a is 1/2.
Then I have 1/2 plus or minus
the square root of -- what?
What's up here?
If a is smaller than 1, this is
negative and if it's negative,
its square root is imaginary.
So this is good.
I have a real part and
then an imaginary part
and then on some magic
little bit of board,
I'm going to add their squares.
So I just want to take the real
parts squared and the imaginary
part squared -- now the
imaginary part is going to be 1
minus a squared because
when I bring out an i,
then I have a 1 minus a squared
there and when I add them,
I get 1.
So let me just say
again what it is.
I just figured out
what is absolute value
of G squared as
real part squared
and imaginary part squared
and I got the answer 1.
So the conclusion is, the roots
are stable when a is below 1
and I have instability
when a is above 1.
Then if I track that down,
that reduces to the tests --
it just happens to be
the same test on r,
whether r is below 1, which
is the Courant-Friedrichs-Lewy
condition, that I'm staying
inside the characteristics,
or r is bigger than 1 and
I'm taking a delta t that
isn't stable.
I'm sorry to go
slightly over the time.
Thanks for staying with me.
I'll begin next time
with this staggered grid.
That won't take
the whole lecture,
but it's worth knowing because
we see staggered grids in many
of the best methods.
Thanks.
Have a good weekend and I guess
it's Tuesday rather than Monday
that I see you next.